hello readers today i'm in this peaceful
forest to tell you all about the skill
of figuring out the main idea of a text
say what's the big idea yes exactly wait
what oh hello squirrel you heard me big
legs what's the big idea with you
tromping all over my patch of forest
without so much as how do you do i'm
sorry how do you do hello how can i make
it up to you well okay i'm working on a
school assignment girls have school yeah
all right all right sorry go on so i've
got this newspaper article and mr
badgerton says i have to draw out what
the main idea is how is that different
from a summary okay a summaries all the
key details of an article or a story but
a main idea is bigger than details it's
what those details add up to a main idea
is the key information that the author
wants you to know after you've finished
reading the text so for example what's
going on in your article it's about the
creak in the forest and how everyone
wants to drink from it but the otters
want to swim in it the bears want a fish
in it and the beavers want to build a
dam in it and turn the whole thing into
a pond not as peaceful of a forest as i
thought huh not so much no what you just
told me is a summary of the events of
the news story but the big idea there is
that there's a conflict or fight over
who has access to the creek so you just
zipped all the supporting details out of
my summary and made it more about the
ideas yeah exactly the main idea is that
different animals want to use the creek
can you give me a more complicated
example i would love to
why don't we take a look at this text
about brain growth
so here's a passage about training your
brain
i'm going to read it i'm going to make
notes and then i'm going to summarize
each paragraph
and then i'll take all those summaries
put them together and that'll help us
come up with a main idea
so
here we go
your brain gets stronger when you
exercise it just like muscles get
stronger when you exercise them
training your brain isn't always easy or
comfortable in fact your brain uses up
twenty percent of the oxygen and blood
in your body because it works so hard
okay so
your brain can get stronger but it's not
easy
here are some examples of how your brain
grows when you learn new things learning
math strengthens the parts of the brain
that are linked to memory thought and
action
imagine that remember when you first
learned how to add and subtract you got
faster and faster with more practice
that's because your neurons those are
brain cells your neurons were learning
how to work with each other and then
your memory improved but memory is
useful for more than just math i'm going
to underline more than just math that
same part of your brain helps you
remember basketball plays dance routines
and even nice memories with your friends
and family
so it's not just about math learning and
practicing things helps your brain work
faster
learning or practicing anything yes
anything learning and practicing helps
strengthen and change our brains
your brain is changing and creating new
neural pathways which is just another
way of saying brain connections right
neural is similar to neuron
so it's like
having to do with brain cells
your brain is changing and creating new
neural pathways when you struggle to
learn something new so struggle is
important in other words there's a lot
happening in your brain when you're
learning all learning can build new
information pathways but learning things
that are challenging for you can
supercharge your brain growth
in other words the more you're
challenged the faster you learn
so here are here are my paragraph
summaries your brain can get stronger
but it's not easy learning and
practicing helps your brain work faster
and the more you're challenged the
faster you learn
putting those three things together i
would say that the main idea of this
passage is that learning new information
can strengthen your brain
let's get our little thinky pinky back
in there what i did was i took something
from each paragraph and found what they
all had in common there were some
details for example about math or or
dance practice that
are important but aren't so important
that they need to be included in the
main idea all of that can just sort of
be pushed into this broader idea of
learning new information makes your
brain stronger can strengthen your brain
so how should i be thinking about main
ideas
all right so are you familiar with the
expression you can't see the forest for
the trees david i live in a forest of
course i'm familiar so it means right
don't get so hung up on details that you
can't see the big picture the trees one
by one are all part of the forest they
make up the forest right you with me yes
a summary of the forest is all the
important details there's a stream here
there's a birch tree here a douglas fir
tree here a red oak tree here a rock
there but the main idea
is this is a forest all of those things
together add up to the idea of a forest
but do they add up to you doing my
homework assignment they do not on nuts
you can learn anything david out